SPEAKER_00: It found a flawed, launched decision process.
SPEAKER_00: It found communication failures.
SPEAKER_00: It found that crucial information about O-ring history, temperature concern, and continuing engineering opposition did not reach key decision makers with the force and clarity it needed.
SPEAKER_00: The people closest to the hardware had the sharpest version of the risk.
SPEAKER_00: The people with the authority to stop launch received a softened version of it.
SPEAKER_00: The commission described the immediate failure, the part, the launch decision, and the communication system that softened the warning.
SPEAKER_00: Diane Von later named the larger pattern, the normalization of deviance.
SPEAKER_00: A deviation from expected performance becomes normal because the system keeps surviving it,
SPEAKER_00: The phrase is useful because it does not require a conspiracy.
SPEAKER_00: It describes a slow adjustment in what feels acceptable.
SPEAKER_00: The line moves because each previous crossing did not end in catastrophe.
SPEAKER_00: Challenger is taught in engineering programs, business schools, and organizational behavior courses because the pattern is not limited to NASA.
SPEAKER_00: Repeated near misses create false confidence.
SPEAKER_00: Every time a system survives a close call, perceived risk can drop.
SPEAKER_00: The near miss gets counted as validation instead of warning.
SPEAKER_00: Missing data gets mistaken for safety.
SPEAKER_00: No evidence of failure is not the same as evidence of no failure, especially when the dangerous condition has not really been tested.
SPEAKER_00: Schedule pressure changes proof standards quietly.
SPEAKER_00: No one has to announce that the bar has moved.
SPEAKER_00: The bar for stopping can rise inch by inch until only certainty of disaster justifies delay.
SPEAKER_00: Institutions reward continuity over interruption.
SPEAKER_00: The person who keeps the line moving is easier to celebrate than the person who stops it for a risk that might never become visible.
SPEAKER_00: Anomalies become background noise.
SPEAKER_00: The first time something unexpected happens, it gets attention.
SPEAKER_00: The fifth time, a tracking number.
SPEAKER_00: The tenth time,
SPEAKER_00: It starts to sound like how the system works.
SPEAKER_00: These behaviors appear wherever the cost of stopping is immediate, and the cost of continuing is statistical.
SPEAKER_00: Healthcare systems, financial systems, infrastructure, software, any organization that has to decide whether a warning is strong enough to interrupt momentum.
SPEAKER_00: Challenger did not invent this pattern.
SPEAKER_00: It made the pattern visible.